quando ho iniziato ad andare a scuola
alle superiori uno dei primissimi giochi
per iphone su 100 flores non so se vi
ricordate oggi proviamo ragazzi cento
floors partiamo dal piano number one
in che cosa consiste questo gioco
fantastico consiste nel superare i vari
piani che ci sono andando sempre più in
alto
sono proprio bravo la cosa divertente
che ogni piano per essere superato
dobbiamo affrontare delle sfide tipo
spostare un cestino mettere ok per
pensiamo già al secondo
voglio vedere dove quando a scuotere il
telefono giusto fantasy all'inizio una
cagata poi ce ne sono le difficili per
adesso niente di così strano effetto
siamo arrivati all io non sono un
esperto di animali però qualcosa mi dice
che i serpenti non russano scusi signor
serpente che russa svegliati test di
cosa sta indicando non c'è niente li
aiutò scende niente sicuramente devo
clicca
non è che lo trascina dovevo trascinare
il dito chiaro 13 ragazzi ovviamente al
piano 13 cos'è che trova una roba horror
trovo il martello al martello e qua lo
prendo
lo uso per testare il muro è stato
difficile ci mettono a dura prova il mio
ingegno questi livelli em up equa già
iniziamo ad avere problemi
altro ancora il martello posso spaccare
le cose quindi io devo schiacciare in
sequenza di tasti che mi indicano i
simboli quindi il primo è l'uno poi
deduco sì al 6 giudicare dall apertura
del secondo simbolo poi e 4 e infine il
3 3 perché non mi davano i botti in base
ai videogiochi avrei preso dieci in
tutto cacciavite non lo svitato la porta
beh non è così difficile siamo lo
riconobbi difficile ma forse perché non
sono ancora arrivati a livelli difficili
però se faccio l'in all
lo so devo fare come si permesso scuoti
con un secco non sai ke kazzo fare
scuoti che è meglio quando non vi
risponde un vostro amico che visualizza
fate così vedete che arriva al messaggio
forte e chiaro allora ci sono due tasti
che vengono schiacciati girando il
telefono uno lo schiaccio pagano no come
faccio a mettere la palla sia da una
parte che dall'altra impossibile scuote
il telefono che strano non funziona
queste serie zio non sapere proviamoci
cosa devo fare qua far cava cà marta
cosa può fare la pasta lo so le linee
sono in base a quello che devo cliccare
quindi una sinistra 2 a destra così poi
tra sinistra 1 2 3 e 2 a destra giusto
credo a me o minchia un ora per sta roba
porca vacca sono youtuber non ci arriva
certa roba non potete pretendere il
panno per pulire bene non puoi sfondare
il vetro direttamente no puliamo up devo
pure certi livelli che devi toglierti il
cervello metterlo in un frullatore per
riprendere la poltiglia rimetterla ci
sono altri che sono da deficienti vabbè
aaron so io questo l'ho abito di tipo
questo da mongoloidi ci ho messo un
secondo come 21 ragazzi
e che devo fissare la porta si è aperta
era una gara a chi chiude prima gli
occhi di fissare l'avversario vinto io
next level così posso grattarci il
parmigiano su sta roba qui c'è una
sequenza come la capisco la sequenza qua
c'è un an quindi nord
ah no ok news nord est ouest sud nord
est ouest ace che è la luce o ne sono
partiti 300 euro a facce lunghezza del
codice che quasi sbaglio i tasti mia che
erano la il conto in banca propria
famiglia l'ho toccato due tasti ma non
della 300 euro sono povero paga non sto
capendo al buio non vedo differenze se
non diventa scuro ma non capisco cosa
debba servirmi a due miglia il pannello
di prima ovvio schiacciati a caso non ci
aveva un senso sta roba vabbè ma mi
prendete per deficiente cene se ci sono
i livelli tipo quali prima che era un
macello ma allevato pur 300 euro e
questi ma cagata c'è mattino non parve
lo giuro non ho parole non ha senso
qua dovevo fare delle cose tipo guardare
lo schermo schiacciare questi non ho
fatto niente di tutto questo fatto a
caso è ce l'ho fatta bene parigi ai
ragazzi vi faccio i compiti in classe li
facevo così per la madonna 5 secondi
l'itas vita bomba aiuto
cos'è sta roba dei profondi dietro la
serie non puoi passare io non posso
passare ma sai chi sono io come si
disinnesca una bomba secondo famigia è
così però non funziona a lo devi tenere
piatto perché
va bene grazie trentesimo livello raga
basta dove di tenerlo piatto dio mio
perché vale ragazzi per oggi basta così
e stato bello un tuffo nel passato metà
proveniente esigenza che non ho quindi
prefetti spero che vi sia per cento
ragazzi cosa se vi piace molto mi piace
anche questo cioè non vedo da tiziana
non siete riusciti a mont possibilità da
ragazzi
[Musica]